what we start to read the emergency
evacuation now and the inventor of fire
or other emergency please exit the
building an orderly to the assembly
point located in the market carpark the
fire exit the rooms educated by the
green fire exit sign please do not delay
by collecting any belongings do not use
the live the premises must not be
entered so far today we've given the
all-clear please no traceable to smoke
on these premises and please note this
meeting is all recorded
we've got Jamie Burton who's got a
throat infection so you've got these
right and can you substitute members
any non members attending Tina
now the minutes of the meeting held on
the fourth of July and now we'd like to
receive any declarations of interest
German clips some of the traffic patient
on the whippin declarations what if
you've got this was an independent
committee and we've never had to pick
last but we did so to say that you do
have some declarations is to say that
sometimes you always we've sort of been
on this committee so I just wondered
what was their turn on perhaps I can
clarify for the benefit would be that
wimping declarations don't have to be
declared on any other community because
it is assumed that there's many big
whipping however this in committee is
meant to be dependent and therefore
there's an onus on members to stage if
they are with the reason this was
putting up every reveal the Constitution
became very apparent but some members of
the council did not realize that there
was an obligation to notify if they were
wait and serving on this committee does
that cover patient my hopes and thinking
yeah thanks very much
now there's item six on the ADEA the
beauty so the partnership the consumer
report the assistant director Community
Housing Services you see something the
Committee on the current priorities and
during work through joint Castle Roger
disco Community Safety Partnership okay
and say this is our partnership and
report for Domini through its appendix
just updating on the work today up to
quarter one and some future work as well
and we Forge itself would be
complimented by Chief Inspector Glen
Wesley is here with us today as well to
update on the police actions most
importantly to update on the most
current district a trance whirling
emerging trends I just want to draw your
attention to I to three point one in the
report it says the current priorities
have been carried forward for 2017-18 of
course actually save 2016 and the
private use for cloud forward from that
last year as you know but they were
endorse by the local strategic
partnership back in June
I'll be happy to take any questions on
the report before I do I just like 4G
perspective and West earning just to
update and just give them more total
picture on the property at work I think
it's going to say believe certainly
quiet man CSP that I sit on with Louisa
and I close the console point comes used
to be really positive for people to
discuss issues there's clearly a lot of
rumors on collective wisdom around the
table might say so in terms of resolving
issues I'm pleased to say they're both
partners in Roger and Casa point with
reproductive both in terms of a days of
action where we work jointly together
and also in sharing information with
PSAPs an individual or individuals or
location as has come to notice and the
information sharing that goes on between
us is excellent
Jim generally excellent we very rarely
encounter problems or
potholes in Wasilla file-sharing make
sure that's good and that can only be
the angle on the work the room trying to
do in terms of the community police hub
that's been mentioned previously and on
Arthur spoke about here previously he
still very much work in progress
although I set an ambitious deadline for
having the the hub up and running which
would include police officers from my
team plus representatives from classic
when and what for council and the
voluntary sector that was seen as it
would so ambitious for some and now the
grass be removed public in December I'm
pleased to say to being given a project
lead police headquarters from the police
side to push that the final things
across the line and literally that's
we're out at the moment I sat in a
meeting with this particular individual
is managed by township of the role one
was apparent that meeting was that I
thought that the crashing of our police
and helpers perhaps behind the curving
in terms of relevant the mother helps
throughout the county one was been very
clear to me is that we're not actually
one of the more ambitious often terms
between our people together under one
co-located under one roof so I suppose
my summary it will be worth waiting for
or be able to wait for a bit a lot more
than we thought in the meantime the
joint operations that we carry out my
team and Louise's team and over lots of
women and you have to forgive me if I do
see this to white districts lovely she
openeth in a hot water but our proactive
list of operations but we've run
recently for example slavery and modern
slavery and human trafficking
at least operation odd 55 talk to car
washes nail bars etc and if I told me to
be good we thought might be at risk
working there that joint operation
between ourselves and why for so some
good work I was not between the teams in
terms of the setup of my district is
probably what I've disagree emphasizing
this because they offset other weeks
have always been a bit of country
my team is essentially splitting to half
of them deploy from Rayleigh
Playstations down the road the other
half before from County police station
over in Ireland my community policing
team which numbers six contours or 6 pcs
those are deployed from Riley
however they have a parent district
responsibility so half for them if you
like deployed to the course of 20 Rainey
police station again this is worth
clarifying because I think this is
obviously automated for Riley police
station is to open as an operating base
is 24/7 patrols out of there the front
office on C as we all know was closed
some time ago and there's no realistic
prospect of that reopen and obviously
candy island also retains 24/7 pleasing
capability from a response perspective
but getting the front office there has
also been closed and that will not be
reopening that comes most bases in
summary overview I've got some crime
beta which I'm happy to elaborate one is
people would like to do and people want
to say interest in such things
reasonably West stop the bad news first
I suppose I suppose they're the sort of
early for a lot from distribution this
is not this doesn't include coffe the
point this is a role in twelve months
after July of this year and it compares
to a role in twelve months after July of
2016
vehicle offenses vehicle crime we can
post then all the modes of inference
that for most vehicle the numbers are up
we've got a hundred eighty eight with
additional crimes this rally 12 months
the previous one has arrived that 68%
which is created by significant in terms
of what I'm doing about that recently
submitted a bid to my tasking committee
at work to have cemented resources and
we deploy over a series of nights in
around Rochester made am PR the mobile
impr camera the number plate reader
after several nights of no-shows we
eventually got arrested an individual
whereas Tariq I've recently stolen from
over rocks with village as he went to
the ear so that was a really good result
shout that was worth but no
in will continue to persevere with that
as for operation Houston it's a good
working modern will keep on with it
there is a way inanimate if you make
your own luck with these things but my
team being out there should help so
that's something we can they use that
template operation used to deploy that
again as we go towards the late nights
we've also tried to do a media campaign
through our Facebook and Twitter
accounts I don't know when I saw the
Facebook entry of the young lads walking
down with programming and hopefully
trying car doors CCTV footage and phone
call or just opened so I've left it
unlocked at night again we need to
educate people now just double check
without condoms just in one second that
person at that car but deliberately but
so [ __ ] the more it's almost opened
the door and help themselves so there's
clearly a bit of public immediate work
to do there some pressure on that one
in terms of violence offenses we
classify I advance with injury advance
without funny enough both are slightly
elevated this year thirteen percent up
conservative art with injury six and up
invites without injury I just had a
great voice without injury includes and
texting bullying comments on Facebook
and that's what the threats to do harm
stuff like that it's not actually in
recall but there's an inspiration of a
threat both those areas are up the
statistics don't break down how much
that is domestic abuse or domestic
violence but I'll guarantee was
certainly in there some of that mystic
beautiful count for some of that clearly
we work very closely with our office of
operation Juneau which is a domestic
abuse team and partnerships through them
our axis or go on and to protect victims
and encourage them to come forward I
suppose part of the my frustration in
terms of dealing with violence with
injury is that my district yet haven't
been given the body more video cameras
other district around the forks have I
think I've got one youth one unit in my
home district was an officer transferred
in from a different area and built their
camera with them very frustrating
because actually some of evidence
capture is really poor
they prove very impacted elsewhere or
we're still waiting for hours and trust
me it's not through one of asking for
them apparently official reason among
these the server that holds all the
footage from all across the county gets
brought into a big central server and
we've filled that up and they can't just
plug an extra serving because that'll
only last out of six months of that
wakeful ups they're now working on IT
solutions it's also at this storage
facility for the data so until they work
that out we won't get our cameras
because we'll add to the problem I do
get a focus issue it's not something
that I've when control over but it does
we don't have the evidence capture that
other people to enjoy particular crimes
appliance or disorder of concern because
you'd have to fit that thing other than
that I don't you've seen the footage
it's really clear the audio is really
clear and it's very very impactive I
said we don't have it he's not the
answer to everything but it's it's
certainly something that other districts
have that we don't yet turning to more
positive views then the green numbers on
the Charlie on place like burglary it is
drop significantly down by 20% this year
on the roll in 12 months which is 88
less offenses which is really pleasing
we know about the number of successes in
terms of identifying individuals
committing burglaries but up here and
further afield other areas in this part
of Essex and in London got a boyfriend
and girlfriend outfit or recently
arrested over charged with conspiracy to
build which is a new favorite of the cps
blame about 55 different burglary
offences repeated to them at least half
of which were in our area both year and
cost a point I suppose my biggest
satisfaction of that was when they were
finally caught was actually using the
ball pit area having left the
single-bird with a police dog caught one
of them and I spent five days in
hospital which having a hungry please
don't sue knows every injury so bit
summary justice ah suppose so that's
very pleasing that burglars across the
border down but we maintained
around that we have a couple of my
officers have been seconded to what's
called Operation Titan which is
exceeding the small team specifically
look to the fingerprint and DNA are the
implications that come in the technology
now around they's is very advanced and
something that the US and the command
realized actually there was a real rich
vein of evidence sitting there that we
need to dedicate resource to and that
seemed I can't give specifics for our
district because they operate across the
whole local police narrow in the south
but then has some amazement as obstinate
son Randy 300 burglary detection than
here the wrinkles in through pure DNA
fingerprints absolutely including people
who are we banged up in prison stylist
basically then come up on other
fingerprint I think's at the NAIA so a
really successful take monthly so that
our fathers have contributed to that so
that I think has brought the M is put
assault rates or where he's the moment
burglary and last one that the sonic
lamps or appreciated a topic that is
very dear to most people's hearts by
antisocial behavior through the number
of incidents that we have rolling 12
masters eyes down by 97 incidents which
is six and a half percent drop from
where it was the previous year on very
conscious that loads the live with an
ASB issue on their doorstep round the
corner next door up the street still
possibly fill their living with it but
purely based on the numbers of calls
that we receive
we're moving into positive territory
there and again this certain issue
through the partnership where that start
to be impactive as well I think at that
point yes thank you Jim
I'm concerned that that the server that
is not so
that's you won't the server won't be
working
should you have the cameras in any case
applause uh upon to think that the the
Office of Constabulary has not
investigated even further in so how many
cameras are using and what sort of solar
surgery needs however that's beside the
point
are we don't I understand you correctly
in the fact that we've only got three
offices and three PS ohms serve it in
this area Bobby said that the other
three the other photo stream that I've
gone there in the castle point or carry
on wherever they come back how many
times does that happen
there's the community policing team is
one thing six police at six police
constables and six PCSOs they are
spitting graphically the three of each
three constables three pieces a sidewalk
they're responsible for points I'd a
three half responsibility for the right
side however they're supplementary over
by 24/7 response teams so Early's late
at night 24/7 off them operate from a
league half they'll play from campus so
I can only say that I would love more my
committee PCT in fact in my career some
of you have just been should they've
been shortlisted for the team of the
Year award by the chief constables
police it was because the amount of work
later and people know if you brought
them up McQuaid there might be a minute
submitted to you Vicky Jarvis Steve Judd
Steve joins they aren't top top top
people and they get through a
mind-boggling amount of work for such a
small team but they're quite a unified
team they've worked very closely
together with a lot more people meant a
map so I would and I had to correct our
assistant Chief Constable this week
because I've copied into an email where
he reassured a resident that the
communication team of ten constables 10
pcs I was always on hand to help you out
it's one of those things but in terms of
the numbers that's quite significant so
that's where we are a team of stick but
they because they work with the team if
I fit issue in a certain area a bit and
you can be over here at Webster's wide
or wherever they're all work as a team
but geographic responsibilities in terms
of dealing with correspondents and
blowing up a problem solved and they do
split fifty-fifty across the district
another question comes to mind that this
new incentive of switching off the
lights in West's way car park we came
out of the Arctic sea the other night
and obviously we've got their music
coming from the cars they've got their
life sold and that sort of things so my
concerns are and I don't know whether
you have the same concerns is that
should you switch the lights out the
police are always telling us always
leave your car in a well gate area so
that you know you safety on your car and
anybody else that will be Deary
do you consider that to be a good way of
policing by turning off the lights
the lights are back on now it was just a
week pilot and would they be going in at
the moment we're exploring an option
whether we take them out on a more time
version but our be liaison with Marcus
and he's quite at ease about that but
the moment they're staying on and the
outcomes for the residents have been
affected by the noise was actually quite
possible
I hope those who doesn't answer the
question that I have to do the police
have a role in enforcing and trying to
deal with any issues but partner ages
also have a point viewing trying to
design out a problem if there's a simple
adjustment can we make the traffic
designs out a problem or alleviated less
exploring I applauded the campuses
should to try that for a week that they
still walk it was worth the try and as
the reason the feedback from the people
in medium and it was relatively positive
so I would throw out there and if we
want to improve if you want the back
from people express to it it caught all
that's one thing for them on the other
hand there are people suffering if I say
there's a reason issue so we have to
make those decisions don't we in that
case one article
thank you who's covering things to start
with in there's just a few things on the
actual partnership plan the first one I
raised before meetings and I'm going to
a nail brace every single me tell her to
because we get a going missing in
quality and diversity implications on
their report but I think that's really
important we do it and I can imagine
that there aren't equality and diversity
issues on this or applications if there
are we should say there aren't only our
races every single week and I think we
should be starting to put this in the
pond in their reports that's that point
or no move on to the partnership can
itself so moisture around this is this
is a partnership
playing partnership being the operative
word I shoot the common point I'm
looking at version one dream 2017 which
is fine I look at the Carson point one
version one frame 2017 is different I
want to know more it's different
are we working in partnership or not if
we've updated our in and they have an
updated their but it should be a
different firm number I don't think
that's acceptable the report that the
comic castle point website for this plan
also are finding quiet and gives funding
for each of the areas about I think is
quite formative I won't have a sign of
difficult
but in front of us does give a bit more
information on them they called for our
updates so in parties better in parties
worse
Bhavna know why if we're working
partnership we've got different reports
for a start that's the first question I
mean it wasn't done intentionally
I suppose I'm focused on the fact that
you might be more interested to see your
Oxford update so I've clearly just
detailed Roger I'm very happy in future
reports to detail both updates and pass
the point and record no grief is some
overlap because some of these outcomes
are also as a result of constant points
actions
I haven't put money budget in there
intentionally left out and very happy to
put it back in I think it was in the
previous report that I detailed when we
were first setting priorities so again
you know very happy to do a more
detailed update includes Castleton I
just thought for clarity and just to
focus really on what Russia's achieved
because in some areas I think we have
achieved more which is why you see the
update is a bit further young so I'm
quite happy with that I think we should
play dislike the dissident this bigger
reason the definitive partnership and
there's a flat tyre it's a version later
was anything you're trying to if if
there are discussions about which book
you're looking at it's just confusion
which gives it late I'm sorry if I just
got to respond quickly the first
question was about inserting j9 how are
we always that because it seems to be
delayed for most years well I say
without the title everybody's Dragonoid
McNellis we're putting the page yes on
page for fatherhood called Palin refresh
and training a brief November as above
on I am very convinced that this has
been making noises
2016 17 43 summer fruit has been
refreshing refreshing again they still
struggling with the refresh no no I'm
sorry for not clarifying it was
refreshed last year
and when I say refresh people were just
we've trained their awareness was int
again and this is just again a further
awareness session of our partners and
we're doing in DVA week as well yeah so
everywhere which has a J mind logo as
being refreshing have been trained and
are aware of Lee and I'm just concerned
someone don't know about you that was
all where they have a legacy of having
train line in the past and still would
love them I'm just would be completely
they are not aware of it that was all on
that one thank you
there's just three points on the year
that was all the I'll take you then that
if there is a update on here which much
they called for in your 143 on the
castle point one your money's going to
be more players that correct if I can
take that as a given
yeah okay I'm happy about in that has aa
be of that one all I'll say is on page
11 of this report we've got um please
connect safe 13 to 18 Essex please
traffic light facing the the sense one
to spoke to limited and young people
then providing alternative diverging the
activities you've got support in within
that if you've got three the middle
money to support introduction of CPR
Police Cadets
and then put Essex please to update I
didn't know if there was an update or
what as we speak right now the thirds of
cadets are enjoying their past a soma
Nadine school right now so they've been
very successful and I'm going to the
countywide pass out pay for the police
go to the whole course have a Mitchell
College on Thursday so those and it's
quite testament to Steve John and Janet
Nelson and another lady Michael
that program as well as doing their day
job that we've got that successful
outcome so I'm a 14 that cadets that
probably searched go to the winter and
events activities across the bar then
the Fox Oreo final one which is
something linked to this is the the
active citizen volunteers it says to
update by six place but just both
through our question is whether or if
you prove that or true questions really
one is are the active six with
volunteers with their cold
now I'm taking now doing what would have
used to be done by the place I then they
want conducting meetings for you seven
type of collection panels which we we've
lost no it was most other things blue
because I understand that there's much
for nothing eleven access it those up I
our books at the moment and they're
doing the meetings rather than about
attending meetings they are sorry I
think I'm probably on Fraser pressure
very well so we used to have we might be
the police why I haven't air in the
library or they might say come you said
if you kind of session but meeting there
to discuss what's going on yes
that doesn't seem to happen now all the
active citizens taken that year they've
had specialized encounters that same
thing as a trainee we're at the co-op
down and tar pahty event fleet and then
they'll continue to be some others but
I'm more than happen to are they our
Twitter and Facebook pages where the
locations they don't Beach they are do
it knows that are deployed engaging with
people provided some reassurance
literature although available to engage
with in a meeting setting in a community
meeting I wouldn't expect them to come
to the meeting and ask questions okay
because that wouldn't be a proper these
are people in volunteers yes well just
save some wouldn't want exam pay to come
here takes what I'm going to understand
that and the final question on this is
how how do you engage as well with the
fire service and their volunteers
because sometimes you tend to seem to go
you over that we involve which we have a
fire service plan and a place pump right
until they met they didn't know each
other existed and then out don't but
that some of what they're doing
certainly overlaps in in your him iron
we have OCR about our relationship to
their local fighters good in terms their
voluntary sector again
have to be one of those in the campers
not that we're not familiar with it
however is the recent movie our police
and crime Commissioner is now to take
out the fire services the police and
fire from Christopher Essex I can see
spare a lot those barriers are going to
be brought out your work closely
infusion of EMS work in progress
there's video to make there's probably
I'm not carry over there to probably use
a barrier there at the moment which
probably hinders the fire there is a
very very doesn't uterus I don't you
think that to cooperate together that's
not really problem either for young it
will happen in due course and natural
revolution I'm sure thank you thank you
your statistics later kid you just wear
those I'm drug related offenses speed in
fit most assistance speeding one thing
to it because this is crime and social
behavior based you can find drug for
comments at a state based crime which is
the top of the chart there essentially
we are nineteen percent up this year on
the 12 months roll in January which is
60 20 more offenses state based crime
includes an army drugs it would put
offensive weapons counterfeit currency
but the month we I would say the
majority of those offenses will be made
up drug offenses possession of position
with tens apply and offensive weapons
that's essentially victimless crime but
it's a crime or public order as well
within thank you PCC meeting miss
tincture very informative he advises
hibbe-dah can be for five weeks get
admin to Roger at all mmm-hmm how's that
going to do with the inclusive call
private option no that is all to do with
the emergence of an organized crime game
on candy that's in fact I'm there is I'm
nots there late size of their a doorstep
at six o'clock tomorrow morning to
execute a warrant on personally and I
would see that one it's an organized
crime group on can be linked to an
organized crime group at chums fir'd
which were linked to the shooting on the
Garrett for called great battle a few
weeks ago
I and I can happily take my man's table
if that was occurring in Rockford it
would get the same response from me I
wonder a virus like that
take foot in my district that's all so
that's why I deploy my CPT it's higher I
was a carving for the purposes of
reassurance high visibility that done
some amazing work
I felt that actually that nice cause now
rather what Monday they're all back at
writing thank you
you sitting there God to the chrome
statistics that in relation to can't put
on that's in the area that's gone now
this seems to be it's a new type of car
primers seems to be a growing it's
something that started coming over from
America so I've become an issue over
here its relation to keyless car
entering where as I understand it that
the criminals can get hold of verbs
scanners whereby from individuals leave
their keys close to the vehicle say by
the front door which is quite quite a
regular sort of thing that people do is
that they can scan there and gain entry
to the vehicle and drive off with it off
the drive affirm the property without
having to break into the property to to
gain access to to the keys so has there
been any incidents like that in this
area if
there has is a growing trend have you
been are you aware of this new type of
conflict sure once it pushes now I'm not
aware of any of those circumstances but
- however I'm more than happy to look
into it find out if we have we do have
more called occasionally operation
millennium offenses where someone breaks
into a house takes the keys and then
drives the car up the driveway that
tends to happen with michael higher spec
cars high value cars as you imagine well
though I have to see when a Clio key was
taken the other night which was kind of
surprising notice with the renault clio
drivers but it was a la thousand pound
car and they broke in to get the keys
for it but all joking aside that I will
look into that I'm not aware of any with
that particular mo I don't doubt that
that does happen I don't know what the
other obvious quarter inch of water
birds that move your keys further away
from the door mom relax has all the car
manufacturer thought that one in terms
of but then you know as we know with
modern technology these were whether if
I become the latest thing like they I
understand that certain would also seem
to be more susceptible than others
including Ford Focuses I've no in any
statistics of amongst those problems
that's just that happened I would
imagine I would be mind away they had
all the force or the placing of course
graduate picked up on that
I'm not suggesting it hasn't or wherever
they're not as perhaps look into it and
report back trouble if there is always I
always follow up with some appropriate
confidential advice based on what maybe
the manufacturers of the forward Euler
thank you
counselor mrs. basement Thank You mr.
Jim I'm just a point of curiosity with
the vehicle increase left 68 percent
which is quite significant and certainly
Facebook and social media they distress
and that causes is quite evidence but
one of the perceptions and is that it's
not taken as seriously as it might be
you mentioned at the beginning of your
speech about a young man in plumber
Avenue you've been caught or CCT being
what's he get pretended no he wasn't
because that was just kind of like the
following day so the time we weren't
alerted that it came we own rain fell
about it on Facebook when it appeared on
Facebook and then we were animating
quite a world cordless on I'm focused on
but that's the way is the image if you
saw it was actually quite Brian II there
was they clear facial image of the
person the investigation we obviously
have investigated that but we haven't
waiting one at the moment thank you
yes Thank You chairman I'd like to know
if the neighborhood watch is going to be
reformed at anytime we used to dig for a
neighborhood watch a Trekkie we're with
the police and is that going to be
brought back into operation right they
will watch and I'm consulting with my
team yes I think they impressionable
neighborhood watch them and we feel it's
kind of it's stable but I think you
might others have that might be flatline
a little bit I think it's the uptake on
it isn't particularly good there is a
presentation Marta McQuaid has convened
a meeting of the current coordinators on
the 13th of September here and mainly to
reinvigorate the neighborhood watch it
try and in this some extra
coordinators some extra members we would
like when our hub goes live in December
honest I wish December it on the like we
part of that they will be part of that
regressing
order to bring them in I don't survive
my family I suppose and this is not
there's not a police pier I feel
slightly should mean something like
maybe walk what pretty much another it's
decades of that name isn't it it's
almost a little bit tired I think so I
think there's probably in the around the
county to reinvigorate they could watch
them bring it bring into the 21st
century even a name change market
another me I think is clear night for
20-plus years as I've change I think
there's possibly a need to go down to a
real fundamentally without watch for me
a big waited but nonetheless that's just
a personal view not of the view that
Chief Constable but we are going to
through mark on the scene farm
reinvigorate that locally details of
this event on the thirteen if anyone has
even what a parson interest or what I
was a name that might be a market
benefit to come along I'll make sure you
on our website and going out to reach
their feet as well we will try and
really like you put there through the
LDC as well yeah of course absolutely
because the neighbors locals where I am
being pestered with youngsters in cars
wheezing ran the district and you know
it's don't like me funding the police
interpreter so you know what can you do
about it God if they were music rained
like announcer and you see it neighbor
watched as an intelligence gathering
spot yeah she's really where the value
comes in so where did we put when we go
to yeah one of the neighborhood watch
couples and like any I'm about two years
ago so yeah we got nowhere to go to it
no I understand so I was some regular
communication with us there's also
another event on the 26th of September a
Holy Trinity Church but I need to find
out how that one fits with the earlier
one so I'll get some clarification on
that and I'll make sure that you send
through our DC and out Twitter pages as
well thank you Ron
they was chillin you mentioned earlier
organized crime yep particularly we've
cast can be yest and the gangs are
coming out of London now in populated
areas within Essex um but it's a
particular problem with what
redistricting we speak to getting us
also another question there's a joint
operations in respect of modern-day
slavery is there a particular problem in
a bunch of district right if I did with
the first issue first Rockford
mercifully is not in the organized crime
radar I think in fact I'm confident it's
not that's not to suggest there's not
issues that people dealing drugs in
Rockford but when I sell grinds quite
that I mean these people are organized
they're they sell drugs through sort of
secretive phone lines they bring drugs
in from outside and then prepared to
defend their turf with violence if
necessary
hence the Bavo shoots in the hence the
issues or canopy and I'll retry the
point if we know different is happening
watchful to me the response will be the
same will be as high as we could so no
mercifully watch what is not on the
radar so I would CG but organized crime
groups however I'm naive the fact that
it might crop up and what we're going
through them in on Kathy yeah the false
negatives activity we've put on which
includes one's got a place tomorrow
I would replicate that in a heartbeat
and roughly to happen so I think we are
we are a small enclave of the mid that's
free of that the the bigger problems
certainly rest in Pasadena South End
there are clear links it with those
organized crime groups to client who
from inner London
Chelmsford as I mentioned Medicare has
had as an ongoing issue with them which
this I think is the with what the ripple
effect that is layer or can be which
we're trying to deal with so no I think
we're what was it to the minute it would
find it
fortuitous I'm very very happy with that
state it's quite
so not nothing they would know this but
I agree with everything the cleansing
that is not for us to be complacent and
certainly as a CSP were very much aware
that we are in the middle of what
effectively were being surrounded by
county lines which is gang-related stuff
so for example we have gone we're
revisiting for example we did a very
gang awareness session last year we
released again for partners based on
demand this year and also there's some
very bespoke youth work going on in
Rockford Square and you know they might
not want to know this but this is for
your information for your ears only that
one they use being work with has got
very strong links with the South in gang
lines and the month of game so we can't
say if there's not there isn't a big
problem but if there is a ripple effect
being seen and that's just a very small
piece of work so you know we mustn't go
away from here thinking we're not being
affected but there was quite a lot pops
at work going on behind the scenes to
try to do prevention work around that so
we don't become a problem one area you
going up what we try to bring some
knowledge to think when we are gangsters
that grow music go after you don't come
home maybe text mom dad sent on you know
on our father on my team where I am when
we sort of look into those inquires we
don't have missing people what we then
do is have follow-up say right you know
where's he been who's even associated or
she where is he or she been you know and
there's indicators with organized crime
group activity such as a way to turn up
something in a really expensive hoodie
the moment dad didn't buy so as if
they're doing something and therefore
being rewarded which are all indicators
of some kind of game call it grooming if
you like grooming white gangs to get
they know
where'd that do fun comfortable once in
there fun that ages month or month goes
like that so where's the brand-new one
fat comfortable they were will the
indicates that we can look for and we
were alive to that of course the
disbelievers so that that gives me some
satisfaction but I think there is some
that we're not complacent at all in
terms of the human traffic inside again
I think
is an issue that almost hides in plain
sight for office if I'm honest
you know the carwash that does your car
for 6-pound down the road the nail bar
would have you know inherit normally
sort young Chinese girls etc that
they're doing that they they disappear
at night or episodes we're vigilant
about in that hence the day I've
actually did it recently prior to that
of that actually before we actually
found individual who was wanted I think
he Lithuania who want to european arrest
once a little a more Eastern Europe
working here and that was here much of
it so it's not a massive issue as it
might be seen in some but that's why I
like to keep revisiting that as part of
that CSP activity we keep the rules
turned around it then if we do have
people traffickers or learned here
they're going to know they were people
bringing in sort or foreign workers they
may be fully legitimate above all and we
can't you know we can't have it both
ways people knowledge it's really doing
their work but we've been speeding to
serve under CERCLA gradually that wasn't
straight hard you know what the
paperwork so what's going on I know not
it's right here been South in the fire
service are particularly useful when it
comes to how the homes are most of all
come and see how HMOs are caught in a
weird perhaps you know all the game from
the car wash are all then ushered back
to one address and there's maybe nine
people live in a three-bedroom house
five servers are great for applying for
warrants to get into those places so I'm
again that's another tactic honestly we
do encounter one would be robust about
it through the part of our agencies so
again not a massive issue for us but we
are not going place at that yeah thank
you James let me come back
it was just rendered the candy trees as
you said nobody seen much evidence of it
however I've come across in the last
couple weeks a seventeen year old young
man whose that that were who so he
leaves he belongs to a gang and
certainly believes he wears a chain
which gives him protection because of he
belongs to go and he's recently beaten
up side by side and Tesco's
is that a problem I guess it's not the
gang in the sales that you're talking
about gangs but they certainly think
they were ganging they're sinners is
that on the radar is that problem or is
that something that Louise might have
been referring to for example the
ex-gang member that's working with use
of what Foursquare started talking to
him about what real gang is I think you
cannot be wouldn't stop being quite
quiet about it but you know
unfortunately we can't get to everyone
but I don't think that that's probably
someone who is I think I'm constantly
the reason people who are in organized
crime gangs they don't you don't write
about it
no exactly that's why that's my view
buddy know that like they want to treat
under the radar they don't want to be
nice yes I wasn't aware of that causes
other companies instead though where is
it just reminds the guy communities
effectively problems amongst themselves
an area so minor if we were to encounter
youngsters don't you know it was some
sort of badge of honor I think we could
look at five minutes give me a private
advice that I don't mind is negative it
all the way yes thank you I think we've
got one more question
yeah Thank You mr. chairman
we're talking about organized crime and
there's no organized crime in Roger town
but is there an organized growth in the
Rockford area now some of you might not
know what that is but it's the growing
of cannabis and a number of weeks ago
probably going back two or three months
it's a two or three months kind of
report from resident that there was
unusual
dumping of plants outside the allotment
when I went round there yes it was the
remain of I grow and quite a substantial
size grow which obviously I informed the
police they come down and a little it
was cleared away within 24 hours by
Rockland
yeah going around sort of the Rockford
area if you know what you're looking for
and when to look you will see the
remains of grouse are you aware of any
other grows in the Rockford area if not
moment you should have a chat light yes
that there's about me and you have a
chance on this River simply that are we
act very quickly on information around
grows the nice thing about rose water
right is they can't that garbage be
moved isn't a minute drop earring a
collar very mobile growers template for
a static we've done extra the number of
workers across the whole district this
year seized vast quantity of plant
equipment
well the links to mind was hotly which
is where mum and dad had I've got a lot
of cabin at the end of the garden which
they're going for their summers they're
kind of you know you can live out their
son had bitten recent privacy in less or
thing more people convert the size for
them to a minor growth at mum dad didn't
know about until we knocked on the door
you know that was a small little grow
but just the point I say is he's doing
this great the fact that when we get the
information we will act on it what is a
fragment of information we try and put
it together whatever else we might know
information we share through the
partnership etc cetera it's always
really useful so if you were information
pertinent to or you think as a grow I
have exactly so for me outside
this is a truckload of gear that's got
to be chipped
nearly every time now however silly they
are they're not going to be driving
miles miles with this on the back of
their truck although we know yet
that is it within the local three four
miles yeah to be tipped up in oh happy
tidied up to me outside dinner that's
from the best place for me okay
I think chief actor Wesley these are
four very useful and very rich
presentations to show that things of the
choices that the firstly supposed to
thank you very much for that we have a
recommendation at the bottom this report
first proposed the committee resolves to
note that work for joint partnership
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
the optimum charging we will consider a
report assistant director environmental
services which leads to four members of
the effectiveness of the current
approach and charging for the supply of
we've been to new properties and Marcus
Hopson are introducing Leslie thank you
good evening and thank you everybody
Elam they just forget it's a junction
see that lazy Anthony who is the Prince
to a recycling street scene officer I'm
but I'm just just really known for any
operational questions on a day-to-day
Mac the door it just gets an experience
of the reviews
so think so that the report I think
you've outlined really already what the
qualitative it addresses I think the key
thing is a the wrongly undertook the
review that we recognize as a knack lack
ability to track individual business of
the new properties and in many ways
different processes failed wanting
within that sense
so although we could undertake every one
it's not very manual lower should
attract those businesses with practice
going through a spreadsheet line-by-line
identifying which were new property to
try a new breed of onerous process we're
sitting in the longer term that we
tweaked what we do now look at you tease
out those new beads that's ready for a
date to make squealing it's as easy to
track those and then cross-reference
against the challenging to ensure the
same sort of consistency in many ways
have a look at some of our work we
undertook the majority that the vast
majority of the beans were being charged
probably least it was some room for
improvement but the easiest way to do
that you through having a better system
to track those beans so I'm happy to
take any questions on this report on the
larger developments we obviously a quite
a number of the beans going in there
also fire used over appear because
people moving in as as their
developments or progressing have you had
a very good uptake with the developers
taking responsibility for the beans and
as regards other are the developers
painful the beans or are they just
passing it on directly onto the new the
new homeowners the majority developers
before all the larger codes do actually
tiny I mean they don't have to but they
do sorry so in that sense the existing
policy had to just catch it up those
those few sort of smaller developments
as well maybe one or two houses about
majority the developers are actually
paying and so although we cannot be
other airlines we cannot enforce that in
a sense that of sexuality experience
that we draw up qualify will honor those
and even whether it is in the case maybe
has directly approached many
developments in this is our procedure it
was still weak metruff you were seeing
most of the room was selling point to be
the agreements better form to so we're
finding that we are sort of misses
I think that I would take no offense to
that
there seems to be a fundamental flaw
with the process that is in place we
advertised at the beginning that this
would be have been for life no one has
defined what life is in the charging
you've got replacement in 52 pounds for
three over the lighter scheme but
there's no indication of how long you
think that scheme to last and neither
when I grouped up figures before which
brought money provided me with and any
of that money that had been collected or
replacement beings to be put into a
spoon into a budget or kept aside it's
been spent by the council on other
things so we have a policy of charging
for life which is undefined we have in
their cost of replacements of three
beings which makes at the rate that we
seemed to be replacing there would be
quite a short line so I think you're
going to have a review of the
effectiveness and I think that is
something that this needs to be
considered what is the life that you
expect expect our weary coping the cost
or should we look at the life of the
business that we had as say they've
asked for 10 years and perhaps after
that time recharging again I mean that
these are things that need to be
considered you can't say to a resident
like five hundred and sixty eight pounds
for life and then 20 years down a life
so no we didn't mean that and we we do
have a problem when we used to provide
dustbins
in the old fashioned system households
used to pay for their husbands and then
they could supply them for anywhere now
in this case obviously we need a
specialized piece of equipment and it
needs to be fit for purpose so it's
slightly different and I would like that
aspect considered and perhaps
looked at more fully also if we are
going to charge for replacement bins
that money should be set aside not used
in the general funds like that
considered as well I'm not asking for a
decision or a response now but I
wouldn't like that looked at fully
beloved provider regarding to this a
separate fund archive also right and it
is a concern of mine as well the the
report words for counsel regarding the
variations contract wear suits which is
part means that was part of of that
report within the end of that one point
one officer recognizes that we need to
so the income that comes in will
actually sit on when I say ring-fence I
get told off the saying that worker I
miss using one point one terms but it
was certainly sitting at unit so it
should be a specific this society yes
and that's the idea from there and so we
could because because my idea was also
developers asked where did that money go
we can demonstrate there without use of
these I will clarify the one five one so
that's my understanding what what I've
requested male thank you wheel I did
take it up we've got Manning some months
ago she'll probably away and the the
issue also needs to become okay it's 52
pounds but is that a realistic amount
and are we making a commitment that we
can't fulfill so that there needs to be
some sort of clarity it is wrong to go
out through our residents and say you're
paying a hundred sixty eight pen that's
been for life if further down the line
the council decides to change that
policy I'm not suggesting we will but I
do think there needs to be a time to
meet put on that on there was once I've
discussed with council sparing the
folders that you can almost charge for
all the replacement bins
potential for conflict is quite hard you
can I do in that situation
I understand that and a doctor thing
speaks its authorities was introduced
through a three-month period before it
was rescinded the issue the energy
dimensions it's the accusations of what
has happened to your been so you know
when a beam brightest was that yourself
was that the operator being I was
missing the conflict is quite high
it's unresolvable for my understanding
so you know there is I should consider
equally the for the life question my
view is you correctly it is for the life
of that skin make the sting were to
change I know the council would have to
consider then operates a new scheme I
think we need to be more clear on that
and I'd like it looked at fully
absolutely and I don't think we can say
for the length for the scheme because we
don't know how long this game is I think
we need to put the time factor on life
if that is what we're going out telling
them whether that's ten years twenty
years thirty years is not the other
thing we should be clear we should be
clear ourselves in what we're charging
for what we're collecting money for why
we're collecting it and we should be
equally clear and transparent to our
residents if we're living in charge for
a purpose that that purpose is real and
realistic so as I said I don't expect an
answer now but I do expect a full
examination of that aspect thank you
thank you thank you chairman it's just a
couple of questions is where we've got
the resident and fixed penalty Charles
notice ought to be prosecuted if the
resident hasn't gotten beans but there
was beans at that residency yes and
they've been taken away by either the
revert will mean that when they moved
and all the rest of it do we supply bins
to that residents free of charge and I
think we should because they're paying
their chance with tax and it's not their
fault that the bids are being taken away
and and the other thing is with the new
properties I know you said on major
developments by
or single developments as those that put
house in the backyard and that sort of
thing for one reason or another do we
supply them with means or would that
come under the build-up to to supply
those we would usually in that situation
of challenge the resident the losing
example where you have large
applications come through very easy for
us to identify those long at attention
to deal with with those developers where
its individual developments it becomes
two owners on themselves to start
approaching imminent and saying by the
way would you like to buy the bins so we
tend to wake the photons to come through
to us and say you've got to purchase
these bins we make some sort of
compliance that when you build you will
you will supply bins because that would
be that I mean in this one where the
resident is said should the resident
declined to pay and they are not
supplied with a new bin though in other
words they will be prosecuted at the end
of the day they will be prosecuted
because they were supplied to be but if
we make a resolution to to to builder so
that they have to supply the bins then
that means that would then take the onus
away from the resident or the buyer of
the property
my advice from plan was that we would
not be able to do so we should have a
policy that would allow us to do suckers
because if that was actually not I was
thinking why do catchers like there we
go probably the policy isn't there there
was only one there's other conditions I
feel that they would struggle to exactly
if you don't attach a condition that
state they must supply beans in there
so we were in a situation where we've
got having managed to balance work and
paying the individual developments were
not and it felt slightly unfair the
packs room or my subsidizing and it also
to the second so in the second question
was apart from the that what we Jenny's
open that the costs of the bins can can
we reduce that by any amount through
that to that resident you know in it's
my chest when we say the resting he
tries to pay
I can make pay on a scheme or something
like that we've you know that she had no
when you've gotten and doing takes over
but that's why I'm saying yeah that's
like so usually should be bins remaining
I mean sometimes we have actually taken
bit into white or have its residents
whereas can you take those bins away
that that isn't being used it's being
left outside although it's over so there
is a different situation say it's downs
the individual situation that's on but
normally we apply some discretion common
sense though it's already been ounces
council going yeah thank you then just
come back to the knife the steam
question how long does the current
scheme have to go how long will be
contracted oh well we're contracted for
over four years that is it is a scheme I
mean as a collection skin as a collector
escape but if we then so there's a
potentially affair interchange of scheme
because of the one we're asking someone
to pay for the current scheme if we
we're not writing then to change drastic
being the form of collection they does
that form a barrier to us if we've just
charged some 168 pens for a beam for a
certain scheme then what's the political
barrier should I say twedge then
changing the screen telling that go hang
for another hundred sixty-eight now for
different talk to any as you know
anything we bring in the future didn't
change again something potentially yes
it's I'm sure we're going to change
dramatically from this existing scheme
that's what was willing to lease of
integral authority Authority Council I'm
asking because there we did it for a
year ago two year ago we we have to
reconsider the format of our collection
anyway we did yes that wouldn't that be
would a consideration such as the life
of the school fee and the charging of
residents further for the same service
again with that would that have been in
that case but permissible reason not to
change the collection of consideration
we have that something round
charging a green waste are so very quick
as I know it's not popular I mean
certainly and I don't think that any
impact
it's only way was it was set up we'd
still be justified the charging for
those of those beings and during the
consideration of this policy was unaware
at any for new build properties but
obviously in the event of a change of
scheme would be potentially recharging
the new build properties which are
currently in childhood was a
consideration that they might have to
charge more residents for bins because
that would seem to be the natural
conclusion policy my opponent I think it
was a fleeting consideration but my
advice was was that the operational and
the conflict
it's not worth the consideration if it
helps my personal advice on one way out
question which probably is probably
quite unlike if I just wonder if it's
being acidities obviously the they have
the resident has to provide their own
the receptacle compliant without your
specifications if they do so do we have
the systems paper if identifying when
they fold up and say can you repair my
bin please let's have one understand I
mean we'd have to put some notes on file
I mean you know you know in the
eventualities that that occurs is
potentially a developer could decide to
do it themselves with myself you suppose
a comic because my main attention
correct
yeah yeah potentially and so that's a
bridge went across I mean you know I
won't pretend that DC's perfect this is
no partly why the dressing yes do new
bins out labels the reason I ask this
because when I look around my area the
amount of people in the wrong things
into the wrong bins beggars belief
obviously I feel that the label might
help to tell these people you know what
they should be putting in it and not yes
they shouldn't currently now that's
something where I see new new things do
something huge
obviously they put their own steps I
roll them in confusion yes I think I
mentioned that in four years time
current contract comes true I mean it
makes the sort question in my echo
something that being mentioned
previously as a way of looking at trying
to save money which is obviously
something that counsel Hakim do he said
to perhaps come to an arrangement with a
neighbor in authority so that you've got
one contractor dealing with two
different authorities obviously that
might cause an issue in relation to the
sort of like the most receptacles
because as an example with ruptured and
Southend joined together to have a chief
or contract overall but there's
different sorts of waste receptacles
used in both areas so how would that
affect the sort of like the the Bema
scheme as it wearing in individual to
find business for life situation lady
there are always implementations that
are have to lock into the my view of the
life for life is the life of the scheme
you know so I suspect the majority is
thing will not change significantly so
therefore you said it's a three-bin
system in all probability we may go to a
full bin system the long-term we may not
do so yeah but it's a you know but I'm
suspended always being at least three
minutes looking at current EU
legislation on top of us
may not apply this much longer and it's
hard to get a steering where whenever
God was setting terms of the thing
between timely sake that will be locked
into some sort of three-bin system to
quite a long time but we're also
contracting
let's get the council to collect in a
certain way we didn't we are
incentivized deflecting this wine so you
know you first example if we decided not
to drop this thing tomorrow anyway would
cost a significant amount of money this
council on your bikes is so easy it's
about a half million pounds and
centralization just for doing something
and so therefore you know and there's
quite a few years quantities of that
specifics things but I that's the thing
upon the definition of one of my view of
life they would be life of that scheme I
think if we started to work with other
district councillors and you know
everything that would be up for the dis
our council to decide where those but to
give you a clue somewhere like couch
Esther already has poor different
systems operating with its own town and
and I mean they have bags they have this
they have that I have all sorts of and
if you go here across the whole county
the various operational procedures that
each district has got some of them are
quite specific and operate like our one
does here works well in this district
but it wouldn't necessarily work well in
Colchester where they've got old
terraced houses Ralph on row Oakland and
they've got nowhere to put three bins
for example so I think you don't as a
district we would have to think very
carefully about the implications of I'm
not saying we wouldn't but you're quite
right there would be saw all sorts of
knock-on effect so we have to take him
into account while we were negotiating
that sort of thing I thank you for Larry
I know what Marcus has said again that
it's the life of scheme but I don't
think that is an acceptable definition
of residence which otherwise that's
babies but just thank you pleasure to
come up the issue that I have actually
is with the recommendation I'm concerned
and councils invoicing system is so
koala that we can't
five properties came along but that's
beside the point but the recommendation
says that it reveals the effective be
undertaken over three month period once
have you been invoicing system is
operational well when is it going to be
operational I mean how long is a piece
of string we do I don't think that this
should be left for an indefinite period
so I would like to see some time span
put on that to report back I think one
could put put a title it was more poles
benefit that when he wanted to review a
review period so he so the new system is
up running this month so I would say
sort of end of October three months from
it but it was just I think once be
presumptuous enough to say I'll come
back to review certain well but we need
to know when you can come back to review
each other we don't so if we can say as
soon as possible after January or after
to the end of the year as soon as
possible as soon as committee determines
understand during 18 I think we need to
have a some something more positive on
the recommendation in future allow that
minor change mr. chairman
thank you now there's counsel's name
just a little question really Marcus II
I know we're talking about bins but I do
happen to have a resident and keeps on
putting stuff in the pink bags and
leaving it at the song I mean because to
be needful is there any chance I mean
does he can you not get them picked up
when the bins are emptied I mean you
know it's such a silly thing there in
the I was gonna [ __ ] you about it but
while we're at this stage it is a case
of a nuisance so now the foot traffic
but I was hooked to everybody else
industry does he need to phone you too
or can i phone you too because he keeps
bought back on the beat and I keep
telling even phoned them up but I mean
if you're happy with me to do that and
I'll not mess up my place and then I'll
get rid of them yes yeah that'd be group
Thank You mr. chairman
and to touch base on Campese were
supporting that regards to stop
recycling and what goes in which bin I
refer residents who asked me to the
website because it sold on the other
coast and but attached on the counter
Stanley's point regards to the sorry
what's portrayed I'll come back to
whether recommendation is that the
committee resolves that review
effectiveness we've undertaken over
three months clearly once a new in
invoicing system is operational to
understand extolling this month it feels
like this one so what we are going to
say they are going to invite me back
January 15 percent of every - every week
but everyone in February progress
I'm indicating to speech right sometimes
it'll confuse those that come in the
territory is dead and I really would
like some minions to be taken on this
issue so then the events the deep and
distant past also relate to the present
if you remember chairman of the
committee the third and the allocation
of affordable homes to sanctuary to full
council and there was a report which was
listed here as item 12 on the 18th of
July members who were at full council
will know that I was I was a little
disappointed with that report so I asked
some further questions and mr. Gao is
has very kindly picked up those
questions and put them on the briefing
note I would just also like to say that
in the minutes of council reacting that
July it was indicated that officers
would answer those questions and
returned to all members but I haven't
seen anything yet so I'd like this
committee
to take over this from me and the
conscience and you sure that there are
answers providing to these questions
particularly as the original subject
emanated from this this committee all
the questions that I put there's only
one that I've been able to deduce
anything at all from past counsel
records well actually and also the
Southend echos records the first
question that I asked was why did the
council largely forgo the delivery of 50
affordable homes per year over 10 years
when it's housing register and the
numbers on it very increasing well
you'll know from obviously galas are
circulated to you but there was a minute
and where the issue of the expectation
or aspiration of 50 affordable years
portable homes provided by sanctuary was
was raised that this committee and it is
actually required I won't comment on it
because I wasn't actually present and
not actually the jobs on the committee
at the time but up but I did hear that
it was an unsatisfactory outcome but
since then since that date the council
doesn't seem to a pursue it either so I
don't wanna make a big thing of it but
if we're not minuting it and we should
then it's a case that we didn't we
didn't pursue their desperation and
expectation following that review that
at review committee which you've seen
the minute of I'm just going to say
personally I regret that because
obviously with our homeless register
having risen to 893 people with 90 odd
in temporary accommodation I think I
think
should have as the second question why
the council didn't fix the number and 10
years of delivery at the outset of the
group I don't know and I'm looking
forward to reply the question of whether
development program that sanctuary have
was discussed by those members of the
Council on the sanctuary committee is
something I don't have an answer to but
I think it's important to know and more
particularly to know if we are on as
individuals already on develop committee
or on his substitute bearing in mind
that we've already voted on this
agreement which contains you know her
requirements of sanctuary does that in
any way likely have an investment board
you know fetter our ability to to make
decisions as to the last question I
don't know where I got to and said that
but I'd actually don't really see that
that's relevant now so who made it
inheres maybe I don't I don't actually
recall the context of that so chairman
my conclusion is that I'd like this
committee to pursue the matter of
obtaining answers to the remaining
questions from the offices so that we
can monitor them here proposal it is
um our technical Icebar think I probably
should dare declaring Chris as a member
of what Patera sociation pulled for
three years
drew is he really not currently a member
I think for a couple of years something
just in plain basically made a
resolution deep on answers supply to the
questions we'll take that back to view
your offices the office of machinery and
endeavor to get the answers Thank You
mr. chairman I'm just going to say it's
the offices are unable to provide
answers before the next few committee
perhaps we should ask them to attend and
explain why they can't give us answers
to these questions but I mean least this
is July we're now September the next
meeting it should be a simple thing to
have an answer to a question especially
when it's been directed by thought the
council so if we can't get them perhaps
that where you can get the officers to
attend and explain what the difficulty
is if that's acceptable to the committee
[Music]
[Music]
moving to the next item just just just a
little bit of a next magnificent some
information was circulated in relation
with sanctuary which was requested to be
circulating through the community
photographic system zero
is there a matter when you're looking to
discuss it it just perhaps put an
explanation in relation to because
obviously I was given headed when we get
to the birth plan and I say unite
sanctuary
and going yeah let's just just want to
wait we're a team so those annoying yeah
there's four outstanding items as enough
on the county highway Rangers German
your recall words and the previous
meeting council hood white raised the
question of the planning policy
subcommittee not not meeting and we
asked their officer to go away and find
out why that was the case just to
comment obviously with a number of items
on this key decisions document all of
which are evidence I know that there's a
view that says if you have to accept the
evidence and there's no need for you to
do anything but I actually don't agree
and I think this review committee should
think about it because every bit of
evidence has an implication and at the
moment we're not discussing the
implications of the evidence and there's
no meeting of any sort determined to
discuss it Princeton's
he fish the schwa excuse me I'm talking
in tongues again and the schwa has been
revised and gone through that's been
accepted as evidence but there are
serious implications of of action and as
they will be for the Aetna the Essex
gypsy and traveling traveler
accommodation assessment
the shedder are they called extra-large
with each slaw that means that I just
have a different language and the
southeast six retail study all of which
have implications and the risk is
chairman that if members don't get into
a formal setting to read these documents
receives summaries and to think about it
then when it comes to having to do more
about the revision of the core strategy
will be behind the curve and will be
something like eight or nine ten
significant evidence documents to try
and assimilate my own view is if you are
running a project of this nature and you
really want to consider them as they go
through I understand the implications so
I don't know whether as the Gala's has
had the opportunity to ask questions
that we asked last time but if he hasn't
and I just raise the ante yeah we just
on the back of eight seems that the
planning policy subcommittee is only
really addressed matters relating to
public consultation and I would afford
that matters of reports and evidence
should be part of the remit of that
that's that subcommittee is wrong
this counselor mr. Mason said a few
certain officers is that it's only an
evidence document listen to the tape I
would suggest you invite the assistant
director different services he's twice
at ease to the next meeting to discuss
its let's set him with a particular task
then let's set him with the task of
considering all the pieces of evidence
that have gone through since we decided
we had to do a revision of our core
strategy and get him to explain to us in
summary level what implications this has
for a vision of the core strategy I'll
be pleased to receive that I pleased to
receive it in writing in other words
what a quite a long reward and I'd love
him to come along and speak to us as a
committee if he doesn't want to speak to
the flowing Policy Committee because he
has the view that it's unnecessary and
I'm afraid this committee if you agree
with me does okay
I'll just make one point that we're
being told at least documents are purely
evidence-based but evidence sometimes
depends which way you look at the
evidence and there there are often
subjective conclusions and different
conclusions to the same evidence just to
take an example the toilet survey our
viscous can include I think they were
really used but the survey was taken at
8 o'clock in the morning and they were
quite highly used now I'm not arguing
about that decision what I'm saying is
it's subjective you can have evidence
but your interpretation of that evidence
is always going to be subjective and I
think we need as scales the most and
others remember some said we do need to
look at that we do need to understand
what evidence is available and
understand it's moving forward it's very
important it's just on a another point
on the report I assume that Oh 617 and
oh so a 17 and now the on the 31st of
August decision of course images you can
go through for those two and it's now
the fifth of September all right so I
think it's then I mean it seems to me
that the dates are very flexible nothing
we could almost describe them to date
when we think we might get a report out
they probably won't be that date column
very rarely to listen to meet the
criteria and I've got no doubt that they
would they were sniffing because there
was have got 30th September will be
November
can we have 10 to 17 to that
probably yes that one's for the healthy
ones going out doing same same point now
what are you ready yeah so are we able
to provide officers with that we might
have a realistic data I can understand
there are about side edges to the
workers what we do to make sure because
the only causes problems yeah for me and
everybody else is me but I'm reiterating
I don't be easy about first from the
resident suggestion you've all seen
obviously on the brief residency now
that suggested the council's speaking
and the camps were social media policy
there's a suggestion for the January
meeting and I'm actually pleased it was
leaning money so to me
counselor I will will stand yes I was
really interested in this because I
think mr. tipless happens to be a
resident of my award hour so that's a
some interest and I don't think he's
just talking about social media
I'll get the very real impression
reading between it he's actually making
suggestions about future projects of the
council as well as how the council
communicates generally and particularly
through through press releases and all
sorts I must have met my own and my own
thoughts when I read this was to say
yeah okay so this particular resident
has a particular interest in Twitter
those of you who have read the Brady
action group in the last there's a
Facebook page in the last month or so
will know that obviously I am aware of
mr. Tippin sees interested in using
Twitter and I actually put onto that
Facebook page have any of you people
please use Twitter and you know what I
got the biggest risk set of responses to
a question on the Facebook page to that
question and I thought they were gypped
there was a handful out else's out of 50
or 60 and you know it told me that
Twitter wasn't you know the sort of
social media that our residents seem to
you know want to interact with having
said that we obviously need to do a
research and as he seems to be
suggesting that we need to do more we're
talking about bulletins and post
information
we have dated you know I actually think
that this is a job which is so
wide-ranging and covers so many issues
including potential projects all those
should go to the managing director
because I'm not sure that I can sit here
and cut this up I could I suppose but
cut this up into which portfolio holders
and which offices should do with each I
think we'd end up with a fragmented
response and very hard to understand so
I think I'd like to recommend that this
particular item as produced by mr.
tippers goes to our managing director
and he uses his office to develop
catalog look at the issues involved and
come back to the committee with a report
and I'd like to invite mr. tipnis to
come and and actually respond to that
because he's troubled this is the one
run read-only resident who's troubled to
respond and he's responded you know in
Sunday
I've doors opening what's up with a
hypothesis whitter large organizations
can use it because in the short sentence
you can lead to leave something saving
the bim's example when there's any
changes in that you can quickly see it
click the link say we haven't actually
discussed advantage for people but we're
going to say much the same I think I
just reinforces our do support careful
Mason says if you break this CD he does
talk about his company using other means
of communication as well a variety of
ways from automotive suppose the context
a regular monitoring etc he talks about
lots of different ways and it certainly
is much bigger than just Facebook or
Twitter there of young people do not use
Facebook or Twitter they use things I
don't know the words it's beyond that
with more than twenty can tell me about
so it goes back to the more mundane as
well such as to have press releases and
press office and communication I think
it when you look at this it seems quite
small but actually it's a very big
subject look good quick insight of what
has the Mason said
I think about it how they could actually
move this forward
I must have make mr. chair I'd be
concerned is he going gesture for
communications to cover because it seems
some of the information that comes out
for those inaccurate and out-of-date and
I could quite something's what I'm not
going to and I think one of the things
that you have to be very careful with
with this type of communication is so
instant is that the information is
accurate factual and not at all libelous
so I don't think managing director in
serious that is the right person to
determine have the way forward
particularly is a sort of diffuse thing
but if notice resident
he's been selecting the form on the
website he was complaining about the
response time and of course if you had a
hashtag for that it goes straight to the
right person's desk and they look kind
of the getting lots of them think it was
a problem you can see straight away
today's an efficient which is factory
housing they requesting
[Music]
I know Cassie Hughes asked me to email
it wasn't just the issue with the photos
the issue is they don't seem to be
talking to residents you email them you
talk to them they do not come back to
again that is one of the biggest
problems that we are actually having
with thankfully at the moment bad
internet is that the photos are such I'm
sure that these counselors around here
probably could go to properties in the
area in come up with some similar sort
of things the the issues with the
property
obviously the the thing that's kicked
this off in relationship to looking at
dealing with it the issue that weeds of
bringing forward to this is specifically
that it's how sanctuary has dealt with
us in relation to our communication
because just act accounts are used
initially when these issues will arise
in from residents got in touch with
Louisa Moss and said to her what's the
best way for me to deal with this and
Louisa
gave cleaner a way of communicating with
the best way to communicate the same
and to get a response but the response
that we've had direct from them as being
in feign respect of how they've dealt
with some of the residents it's not been
they say that they're going to have a
meeting but won't give an indication
where the meetings going to happen there
is we know that there is work which has
been budgeted for to be to be done on
the property that won't give an
indication has to win it's gonna take
place so we just feel that like the
residents that we've attempted to find
out information on their behalf but we
we sort of been kind of [ __ ] off
without any specific detail and stir
when times three indicate they it's it's
obviously on a list work they're gonna
do but they won't tell us when they're
gonna have a meeting with residents when
the work is due to be sugar was to be
done and they must know this because
it's meant to be done by a certain
period of time okay it shouldn't be
individual incidents it should be more
strategic ie
okay that's the one so now if it's being
replicated across the district you know
that becomes more a committee issue my
issue then is is that we've obviously
had quite a big thing about Frances got
a launch and one of the big issues that
come up about
about how st. we communicated this seems
to be another example of how they're not
communicating appropriately and I think
that's the connection of the wider thing
yes it is is it their repair and
maintenance across the district or just
their communications from the
government's point view okay you have
the sanctuary committees in Rockford the
overseas I believe repairs and
maintenance and looks at that side of it
so if it's just an issue around man and
you're not getting satisfaction from
thank you direct you could speak to the
members of that committee you you are
the council councillor Ward was that
even on communication and you've got
ashore and they could take it up on your
behalf but that for that incident
oh I just clarify when I got your email
we've canceled news stuff I actually
sent this out to Emma Keegan if she knew
she was where I don't know I don't want
this to be just needing to become vice
he's got less points now I did this on
the 31st she came back to me on the
straight of one the first with a
complete list of what was happening on
it I think either the last time she's
put is a residence meeting was held at
Goodman's yesterday I'm in the 31st
yourself then with the scheme manager
and housing officer that's the last
communication I've had with her but so
yeah this is the point we requested but
when they're gonna have anything we've
written
and residents are stars who participate
on their behalf next time they had a
meeting so they've had a meeting and
they're having a nice car but then
that's up to the scheme manager as well
to it you know cuz I obviously on for
mother in the scheme as different scheme
and they she lets me know as so again I
know we requested we've been going to
this was the first counselor to indicate
and quite frankly I'm well put out but
we've just had this almost ridiculous
conversation when I call it a
conversation it's not certainly not
gonna debate and it's not been a debate
on the work plan either which it is
actually the subject on the work plan as
mister Gao is actually introduced we had
a request from members around the table
who were board members who received a
number of complaints issues from
residents of more than one Housing
Association but we've actually alike we
actually alighting upon sanctuary as a
resolution to take forward essentially
have responded I understand their
response but that doesn't mean to me
that's the end of the issues that were
raised to me there were enough issues
raised round the table for this
committee to consider how our residents
are best being served in terms of
repairs refurbishments programs and
complaints and in these since we last
met I've also been treated to a number
of issues regarding sanctuary from their
tenants
but equally I've I've had an other
issues arisen or another Housing
Association I'm quite content that we
have a housing officer and a citizen
director no less with a team to deal
with issues that tenants have raised
we've got a portfolio holder and we've
got this sanctuary committee so as far
as I'm concerned in terms of the
individual events like Goodman's light
signal chicken house relationships light
signal house and others that they met
those issues must go through without
this committee holding them back they
must come to a resolution in the benefit
of the residents and members must be
assured that that that is the case
however it is dealt with however from a
point of view of this committee if we
have a responsibility to know that those
involvement those schemes those
procedures do work so my view is to say
I don't really mind whether sanctuary or
indeed in the other Housing Association
actually comes along to talk to us
because I think in a few months time
would give them that we've had a number
around the table and they should all be
notified domestic hours as I suggested
that we should be able to dissect those
events and determine what went well what
didn't go well and what needs to be
changed and that is something that is
appropriate for our work plan and that's
what I proposed yet
Oh lovers don't even care workers will
often let me counsel Mason isn't wind
power of second what castle Macy says no
I agree with that
I too thought it was around the
management of the repairs and overall by
centering the issue by to have lots of
complaints about this and maybe some
kind councillor dummy probably members
of large bowl
I thought you bring our most to meetings
and I think there's a recognition that
there are issues what how to do them
like they have a continual turnover
directed leavening like dealing with
them and I'm not sure they were still
filled up the problems and I think we
don't need sentry to safety to attend to
actually look at this on behind in their
residence or tenants and I put the
century
are we look into forward details to any
insurance
yeah obviously but we need the details
but there are other avenues to take it
up enough I've already dealt with mine
to take their issues I found the best
response and five
take em up I'm gonna bring with
Chancellor Mason but to find needs well
I think the question that we need to ask
each is our offices aware of what's
going on with century and are they
I've got them to answer the question are
they prepared to carry on with secretary
the way they've a degree for residence
and I like daily and i like putting the
residents first before anything else
because it seems to make the ugly
chairman are probably afraid to put
questions already are we going to do
that where's a hot they not to an
officer who's not here that's all we the
great battle really good
okay we vote you having the meeting
about entry now I think certainly in
dogs the recommendation we had on I'm
sure we will penny Brown from Louisa
morsi's directed photographs in a
private rental properties that were
substandard and yet here we put
photographs of Housing Association which
are questionable well I would like to
ask as well is what health and safety
aspects should we be looking at in
relation to these issues
I mean sometimes they're just poor
maintenance if this is mold and it may
or may not be then that could have
possible health implications and we also
have a Health and Safety Officer so it
seems that we don't need to look at the
process it's and also look whether any
health and safety issues are raised at
the same time the issue of mark
well actually the health and safety they
see our mental health office huh okay
and that's the other Avenue if you know
okay thank you
October 7th is we've agreed that all
members of the council that have had
issues raised by tenants of any housing
association will notify those issues to
Paul not to investigate but to enable us
to use that as a as a log to be able to
see how loans were resolved and the
Badgers but the point I was making this
invitation is scared to 4 million oh
thank you that's all I wanted to just
say that if we're emailing situations
because we should be very careful about
confidential information and about
perhaps not putting addresses or names
in unless we have permission to do so I
think we need to be sensitive in this
situation and use I'm sure members well
but just to be careful not to upset
anyone that's upset further I quite
agree with cancer Christine my son would
not be prepared to put any addresses or
names out to you poll for residents come
to me and confidentiality you know just
one issue say whichever house
Association one issue was and really
need to know if you give me an idea of
the area that you know where what Walter
Olivia it's common sense you would know
what wards were in anyway and I don't
think any of us would be crouched on
anyone else's walls so you wouldn't need
to know the address you need to know
it's in Hawk waste or sorry coke West
issued no what would we read I'm gonna
have to declare but a resident has
contacted me directly on a matter
outside of my ward and has insisted I
deal with it
I have no choice it but it doesn't
really matter what know there is this me
is the issue that we have and them okay
it's a responsibility of the cancel any
cancer I'll move on to the October's
meeting in October we have on
[Music]
[Applause]
yes okay two point one which the two
items are emergency planning University
governance research you never let me
speak assume that emergency planning
because my off script
considered for the work plan we all know
about the ground for disaster we all
know that obviously everything was done
in any emergency that could be done
except that those issues and further
issues went on for a great deal longer
and I don't think many councils have
really thought through how we deal with
sustained policy and strategic issue
affecting large numbers of residents I
do know Michael Hyatt I went to see
Robert Manning over in complete
different matter but he brought it up to
tell me that that officers have
considered this issue
and our considerate position recognized
the potential impacts of this solution I
think we both said we also compete but
if a plane crashed it was a passenger
playing in our district we might have
you know at least grateful if not if not
warm so it's a real thing so to get to
the gift of the chase Chairman situation
is we know that the officers are are
looking at this as the Manning thought
it was a really good idea for a review
committee to have a task group to
consider what some the council was
putting forward as a adjunct or
extension of the emergency planning
procedures that's a sensible actually
suggestion what about training training
both al we would present ourselves
whether what happened to the council the
grant closeout yeah I don't think we can
turn that most of this is an hour or an
hour training session already one of the
areas he touched on was the PR
and as you see temple to the Chelsea
found within the first couple of rounds
I need you know a learning those sort of
things even bounce they were having an
emergency training day terrorism we've
had to play and stand in this area
probably it's all once in the past one
at Eastwood and women on the fields all
right sure
let's do two Y so this those were just
small instances that they yeah they put
the airport there we should be very
aware that it could be a more major
incident
so yeah all I wanted tonight so they can
cite an emergency telephone number now
when I worked in the city and we used to
have the emergency phone number printed
on the back of our ID cards if there was
an emergency and the phone systems of
them so you could follow the a special
number that's totally centralized works
the other way around
the assistant directors etc all in this
world director having said that most of
us thought each other's phone numbers
anyway I don't know how residents would
contact prison you come to the emergency
yeah yeah and then they're put in
contact with the officer that's actually
non-ginger
where can that go on the work planning
little thing nothing
no did you chairman if I might I mean I
thought as the task group although you
know if I now know the officers are
already working on this maybe it's a
simple report and presentation whatever
form you said there was may even be
easier than I thought
that's what they're doing yeah yeah
that's what they're trying to do it now
so join me pence name for January
a point that should be noted is that
when we had the invasion of the
travelers on a particular site and when
the flow of a parish found Rd seemed to
turn man and say you know what this
don't think we what would you expect me
to do and that was the answer which
wasn't very good so tell me say can we
do anything is it a heating Sarge sure
that's always said and I said what's
that the officer on duty
that was your intuitive and he didn't
know what they do so when you get the
idea that everybody seems for that he's
just told us to wait I'm supposed to
work Tim and the person in Basildon was
that this ostensibly is where the number
is it could not physically have have a
list of those people in particular one
duty officer from Rock District
Council's contacting contacts on a
mobile who would take charge of the
situation then involve others and
preside that exactly the same situation
yes hopefully did that thank you isn't
attending
but just for a person who's got a lovely
top ten boots the other week it's great
you get help so I can't go through his
text messages great school tomorrow this
week did you tell you by Instagram what
does that pure text okay are we adding
the refuse bin songs of February yes
yeah anything remains missing chairman
is another item I do put on well I'm
sure our vendors remember the De
Montfort University local government
research field report in fact when I
asked you when I asked mr. Gallagher put
this on the world kind I didn't know
that our managing director was going to
send a copy of the report to all members
I haven't no I'm really glad that he
didn't but I really do think it's a
subject that you know members should now
consider how it impacts have the
recommendations the finding the
opportunities
impact on members of the council no I'm
thinking of much later
you've only got Community Safety
Partnership yeah Kevin I'm not sure
whether we should be asking for a report
from governance and therefore mr. boss
stuff because that's democratic services
or we should we should be asking for our
managing director bearing in mind that a
great deal of change might be required I
think it might be a good idea to ask the
managing director to head this up with
support from mr. boss